1700 no nos falta una pastilla y van a
ortega de 14 años es una ecologista que
salvó a su comunidad de quedarse sin
agua desde 2019 emprendió una lucha por
rescatar la presa madín que estuvo a
punto de convertirse en un pantano
debido a la invasión del lirio que crece
por las descargas residuales además
cuenta que teníamos que solucionar el
tema de las descargas para que no
volviera a surgir el hilo y todos estos
problemas de los contaminantes entonces
fue cuando lanzamos la petición contra
las descargas de aguas negras y aparte
una demanda colectiva legal para para
que los desarrolladores se hagan cargo
de sus plantas de tratamiento que no
sirven a estas o están descompuestas la
presa madín abastece de agua a 155.000
familias del estado de mexico y van a
unió a su comunidad y lograron retirar
el vídeo primero a mano y luego con
maquinaria que finalmente puso la
autoridad mediante una petición en
change.org ha recabado 71 mil firmas de
apoyo me parece una muy buena idea al
principio pensé que va a tener como
tanto tanto apoyo en tan pocos
días y semanas entonces fue algo muy
shockeante y muy bueno a la vez para que
pudiera ayudar al entorno de la presa la
lucha de ivana que le ha valido
reconocimiento internacional revitalizó
el esfuerzo que desde hace 13 años
mantiene el ecologista wenchuán para
preservar la fresa alerta que además de
la contaminación por el drenaje los
basureros clandestinos también causan
daños por naturaleza como casi siempre
los basureros los ponen en cañadas pues
bueno todos sabemos que la naturaleza
tiene su memoria y si llueve entonces
esa agua arrastra la basura
los discípulos se mezclan a las cañadas
oa los ríos y terminan en estos cuerpos
de agua no el plan ahora es instalar
humedales para que las mismas plantas
reduzcan la carga orgánica y de
contaminantes que iban a su mamá edith
no descansarán hasta cumplir con su
objetivo que la presa madín esté fuera
de peligro